Groups allow you to map users to their relevant roles.
This enables you to assign the permissions for a chosen set of roles to all the users
in the group.
Users in the group inherit the permissions that are defined in the assigned roles, subject
to restrictions on sites.
Each user can belong to multiple groups.
They inherit the roles and permissions from all the groups that they belong to.
You can also use groups to restrict users to certain parts of the site tree.
To create a new group, log in to PubSuite Enterprise Edition as the administrator.
From the team menu, select groups, click new group, enter a group name.
In the roles tab, select the roles that you want to assign to the group.
In the users tab, select the users that you want to assign to the group and click save.
You can edit a group as follows.
Again, make sure you're logged in as an administrator.
From the team menu, select groups.
From the list, click the group that you want to edit.
Use the roles and users tabs to edit the group settings.
When you're finished, click save.
You can only delete custom groups.
You can't delete built-in groups.
To delete a group, again, ensure you have administrative privileges.
From the team menu, select groups.
Find the row for the group that you want to delete and use the delete icon.
At the prompt, click delete.